my name is Sarah Silverman and I feel
ambivalent I guess or well that's just
fantastic oh that's great no that's
that's wonderful they don't you know
kings and queens royalty has done this
podcast
really who I didn't think you'd follow
up with a question King
no King what what queen I made it up I
was trying to con you into thinking that
it was a much bigger deal than it was
and now I have to come clean I don't
believe we've had a king or a queen have
you had a princess no no we haven't had
any any royalty no royalty at all and so
I understand now why you're ambivalent
about being on this podcast yeah I mean
come on it's who would we get I don't
even know who we would get any member of
any royal family you get here oh that's
how it works well how do we do that I
don't have any pull with those people I
mean I feel like the ones in those
smaller royal families would totally
come on we could maybe ask them to fly
themselves here yeah put themselves up
very strange opening to a podcast
interview and like I say I've talked to
kings queens
I've talked to them all from bogey to
Bacall but I uh I you know I love you I
do and I've and I have for a long time
and um and we've been in the comedy
trenches together
I like to act like it's sort of like
trench warfare yeah when doing comedy is
nothing like trench warfare right uh
dysentery rats bullets flying
um I remember you first came on my show
and I think it was 1993 when you were
seven years old that's right you were
just a tiny tiny kid when you came on my
show for the first time
and I was like your friendly old uncle
frightened
my name was more of a creepy uncle
no just to you know be on TV oh you were
in front of me on TV no I don't know
maybe you were I don't know maybe on
your show is the best well thank you but
you always seemed
Fearless
always
um and I know that that's not true
but you're really good at faking it
right thank you and uh you're really
good at going out there with really
smart very edgy material
and uh selling it and and afterwards you
leave this impression of sweetness and
light and I always think how is that how
is that possible do you know what I mean
it's a magic trick you managed to pull
off it's like a aftertaste there is
there's a very pleasant
God loves Sarah she's so great after
you're done and then when I look at the
transcript of some of the things that
you've said uh you know I want to have
you arrested
so it's a very very cool thing that you
do
thank you uh
um
there was no question I was just saying
nice things about you I was happy I
walked into the office and you had
already gotten here
and I walked upstairs and
um immediately I see you wearing a
filson's winter hat
which makes me really happy I know
you're from New Hampshire yeah I'm from
Massachusetts I'm wearing
I'm willing the weather to be colder
than it is here in Los Angeles so I'm
wearing a very I think you described it
as very sexy and manly uh
maybe I said that I think it's it's what
it is is it's
um
I would say this is La rugged but
um you know how you can like buy like
thousand dollar sneakers that look like
they're used and um jeans with holes in
them and they're like expensive yeah
I mean I'm just saying like if this were
for actual cold weather it would be
lined it would be lime
what is this new fancy thing of unlined
clothes that's cheaper well I don't
think this is a very I'm honestly saying
this is not a very expensive uh is it a
jacket or a shirt you know that's it's
called a shacket
no I just made that up it's kind of a
halfway between who makes it it's not
like this fancy company a company called
flint and Tinder yeah oh you knew well
the minute you said print I knew what it
was flint and Tinder flint and Tinder
and I'm not doing an ad for them but if
they want to send me some stuff I'll
split it with you okay
um it is nice though I'm being I'm
nagging you because I read uh the game
and uh yeah that like brings them you
know I pray on your insecurities that
you'll you'll want
from me uh more if I uh nag you I'm
always current it's from about 19 years
ago yeah that's fine it was current 19
years ago
you know when people on the internet go
like well remember when you used to be
funny or is that just me
what you're talking about yeah I've
never had I've this is interesting I'm
the only celebrity that's never had a
negative thing said about me in social
media oh my god I've had them scrub the
entire internet since 1993. it's
unbelievable not one negative comment
ever of any kind oh my God so anyway you
get that sometimes remember you used to
be funny
um yeah I do but I get that and I go oh
these jerks they're you know whatever
but then last night I was like
I remembered some old material and I was
like I did used to be way funnier
I mean that is and I do remember it
I mean I was pretty hardcore funny yeah
it's funny because my response would be
you used to think I was funny
wow like what you're specifically oh
what's that
you're all red I just wanted to see my
fingerprint oh am I all red yeah you
just suddenly got red
you know I am as we all know very white
and when I laugh or show Joy my face
gets red in that Irish way and then yes
you can put your palm on my forehead and
if you take it off quickly yeah
oh there you go oh my God oh my God
well the problem is I just burst a
vessel in my brain
so I've got about 30 seconds to live
yeah isn't it funny what we do for to
get a laugh I mean I can like make my
hand look really like contorted like you
know like like this oh my God yeah look
at that and people go how do you do that
I go it hurts you know like I just like
that's how bad I want attention I guess
oh it is uh I can't do that at all just
painful that looks insane I mean look at
that that is oh my God absolutely God ah
we'll take a picture so you can post it
still well I think we already got it
look at that what is this a video
podcast yeah is it really sure why not
oh no no you look amazing fantastic
um I uh
I to that point
if I thought I could make
it's got to be a pretty good sized crowd
I'm gonna say at least 3 500. let's talk
like Beacon Theater some big crowd yeah
but if I thought it would get a really
big great reaction I would shatter my
pelvis
if I knew that that was going to happen
beforehand and they said it's going to
really hurt and you'll get some you'll
be like a year before you walk again and
you're gonna have a lot of pins I'd be
saying but how hard do they laugh right
and they'd say well you know it's like a
four minute four minutes
wow